hello everyone and welcome to today's
live keynote broadcast an introduction
to the all of us research program
presented by Katherine blizzards key
policy director all of us research
program national institutes of health
I'm Alexis Krause of lab birds and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Polanski I will now turn the
presentation over to her hi everyone and
thank you for joining today I'm really
thrilled to be here and they have a
chance to talk with you a little bit
about the all of us research program
which is part of the National precision
medicine initiative so wait before we
jump in to talking about all of us let's
be clear about what we mean by precision
medicine precision medicine is a
personalized approach to improving
health treating disease and finding
cures it acknowledges that each person
is unique in in our habits our
environments and our biology and that
the interaction of these factors greatly
impacts our health this complex
heterogeneity also means that a medical
treatment that works for one person
might not work for another
so a good example of this would be
eyeglasses each of us has
cific vision needs from correction
strength to its stigmatism to focal
distance and that means that one
person's glasses won't work for just
anyone with vision impairment so rather
than using a cookie cutter one size fits
all approach precision medicine aims to
deliver the right treatment for the
right person at the right time to keep
people healthier longer it's it's a
pretty radical shift in how each of us
can receive the best care possible based
on our distinct biological and social
and built environments so 2015 marked
the inception of the precision medicine
initiative a trans agency directive to
usher in a new era of precision medicine
for all this initiative incorporated
activities of the department's of
Defense energy and Veterans Affairs the
National Institutes of Standards and
Technology and the Department of Health
and Human Services and several agencies
therein including the National
Institutes of Health of course the Food
and Drug Administration the office for
civil rights and the Office of the
National Coordinator for health IT the
precision medicine initiative or PMI was
established with a mission to enable a
new era of medicine through research
technologies and policies that empower
patients researchers and providers to
work together towards the development of
individualized care to guide these
efforts the White House commissioned a
task force to craft sets of principles
to shape the initiatives privacy and
security safeguards as well as this
ideological framework these were the PMI
privacy and trust principles and the PMI
data security policy principles and
framework which you can access on the
all of us website in 2016 Congress
passed the 21st century cures Act with
broad bipartisan support the Act
codified PMI and authorized about 1.5
billion dollars in funding for the
initiative over ten years in addition it
included a number of provisions that
indirectly sculpted PMI including
pervasive language on health disparities
and diversity provisions on data sharing
and importantly language around data
privacy while PMI is still very much
across government initiative the bulk of
the PMI effort rests in the hands of the
National Institutes of Health
it is NIH that is leading the efforts
for the all of us research program and
it's to all of us that we
turn next the Elvis research program is
truly an unprecedented effort to build
an immense longitudinal dataset offering
utility to a cadre of scientists from
myriad biomedical fields so talking
about comprehensive data demographic
biological and socio behavioral on a
million or more participants over we're
hoping decades to lifetimes but perhaps
what is most exceptional about this
program is not its unprecedented size or
the multi-modality of the data that
helps to collect but its dedication to
diversity both in the scope of the
participants in hopes to engage and in
the range of researchers that it
endeavors to serve the program exists as
a consortium of partners across the
United States and we'll be adding
additional partners over time these
consortium partners serve different
functions from storing and distributing
data and participant samples like our
data and research center and biobank to
building our website and mobile apps to
interact with participants and
respective participants during the
enrollment process and beyond so the
elements research Proma is organized
around eight core values that will kind
of walk through now I think this is a
really great way to get to know the
program both from the perspective of our
principals but also to highlight many of
the issues that have been the primary
foci of much of the program's work to
date so first and foremost were called
the all of us research program for a
reason
and that's because our goal is to allow
for participation by any interest in
individual so that this resource truly
represents all of us to make it as easy
as possible to participate the program
has created multiple ways to enroll and
take part right now there are two
primary pads to enrollment either
directly through a website or a
smartphone app or through a
participating healthcare provider
organization or hpo in the future we're
hoping to provide additional paths that
make it even easier to precipitator
participate and all the facets of all of
us it's a large part of enabling
participation across communities and
demographic strata is ensuring broad
accessibility of the informed consent
process all of us has taken great pains
to draft all participant facing
materials
including the consent documentation at
the 5th to 6th grade reading level
approximately 90% of Americans aged 18
and older read at or above this level so
by enforcing these readability standards
we enhance the approach ability of our
program to the vast majority of eligible
individuals our consent process is
modular meaning we've broken up facets
of the consent requisite for full
participation into smaller more
manageable pieces at present we have to
consent modules in place the primary
consent which incorporates consent for
bio banking and genomic testing and the
HIPAA authorization for disclosure of
electronic health records or EHR data
next our consent agenda is consent for
the return of information so we can
provide participants with access to the
information the program generates about
them we've also instituted a multimodal
consent workflow studies have shown that
relatively few research participants
graphs salient facts when presented with
traditional consent modalities so to
encourage comprehension we present the
consent materials in both audio visual
and text formats and follow each module
in the consent process with formative
evaluations to ensure participants have
grasped those key facts in addition to
promoting participant understanding of
the program we're also using the
outcomes from these evaluations to guide
improvements in our consent process
helping us pinpoint areas that may need
further explanation the consent process
is 100% digital so if our objective is
to reach the most people possible we
don't want to limit ourselves by
restricting access to the program to
discrete physical locations a recent
analysis by the Pew Research Center's
estimates that eighty-nine percent of
Americans 18 years of age and older
access the internet on a regular basis
so by leveraging the reach of the
Internet we're vastly increasing our
participant catchment potential while
this also creates barriers to
involvement we're working on solutions
to facilitate enrollment and
participation across the digital divide
so if we truly endeavor to be a national
program we must also allow for
participation across the entire country
and for that we've needed to ensure our
consent materials comply with all
relevant state and territorial laws
governing the processes so some of the
ways in which state specific statutes
have manifested in our consent drafting
process has been around things like the
mandatory inclusion of the California
experimental research
subjects Bill of Rights for participants
enrolling in that state some states also
have laws around medical information
disclosures that require valid
authorizations to single out
particularly sensitive data types
including mental health and substance
use diagnostic and treatment information
a sexually transmitted infection status
and the results of genetic testing and
then there are other state and territory
specific statutes that among other
things determine like the age of consent
and create requirements around expiry
dates and witnessing of forms we've had
to adapt our consent pipelines to meet
these demands which has been a challenge
to say the least but all in all we have
a total of about 14 different flavors of
the entire consent process but
assembling this variety of consent
pathways pales in comparison to what
we've begun next which is the consent
around the return of genetic results so
from an initial survey there were at
least 29 states with specific statutes
pertaining to the disclosure of genetic
test results but in truth there's
probably actually significantly more
than that this will no doubt further
complicate the intricate consent
landscape of all of us we're in the
midst of that effort now and I will be
sure to come back and let you know how
that goes so while the program hasn't
made major strides and enabling program
access to large swaths of the American
population we still have a ways to go
both to encompass a broader participant
base and to allow access the full
complement of all of us activities so
one of our first orders of business
after launch is to expand eligibility at
present the program is only able to
enroll individuals at or above the age
of majority who are able to consent on
their own but the program is working
night and day to expand its capabilities
and hopes to be able to offer enrollment
to serve a wide range of prospective all
of us participants in the very near
future including specific efforts around
children American Indian and Alaskan
Natives incarcerated individuals
individuals with decisional impairment
low literacy populations and individuals
with linguistic or physical barriers to
participation we also want to enrich our
current consent materials to facilitate
greater understanding of and engagement
with the program so this includes is
sort of choose-your-own-adventure
consent workflow that allows for
to choose the modality of the data
that's being presented to them a layered
consent as well within forming loops
that let participants delve deeper into
issues that are highlighted during the
consent process and options for
individuals with low literacy the
designing which will be heavily
influenced by ongoing research into this
area by sage bionetworks
and Vanderbilt University two of our
consortium partners and last but not
least as the program grows and develops
we'll be adding more consent and
informational modules to support program
activities I mentioned previously that
next on our agenda will be consent for
the return of results but this is by no
means where our consent pathway will end
so second of our values is that the
program must reflect the rich diversity
of America as you may have heard me
mentioned at least a couple times
already during this talk all of us seeks
to enroll participants from diverse
backgrounds and walks of life inherent
in that mission is the ability to engage
the full complement of prospective
participants but that doesn't just mean
considerations for individuals that are
protected by specific laws and
regulations
it also means in franchising groups of
people that have been drastically
underrepresented in biomedical research
up to this point as late as 2016 only
19% of genome-wide Association study
orgy wasps populations consisted of
individuals of non-european descent
research was repeatedly has repeatedly
demonstrated that genetic risk findings
are not universally applicable that
certain variants confer differential
risk in populations with dissimilar
ancestry this data just reflects gee
wasps and specifically looks at ancestry
but similar discrepancies exist they
exist when examined through the lens of
social factors like race and ethnicity
despite the fact that such social
factors are known to contribute to
disease risk and health outcomes
clinical research overall has generally
been conducted in overwhelmingly white
and often male populations and the
paucity of inclusive data is a major
driver of health disparities in this
country in light of these deficits the
21st century cures Act included a number
of provisions with the objective of
improving representation and biomedical
research the precision medicine
initiative was specifically charged with
ensuring the participation of a diverse
cohort and we've embraced this charge
wholeheartedly adopting a fourfold
concept of diversity
we've spoken quite a bit about
demographic diversity but we're also
looking for diversity in health status
this is not your conventional disease
cohort in addition we're also seeking
out genetic diversity we want to build a
community with people from across the
United States and finally we're
committed to collecting a diversity of
data types because this is a data set to
serve a wide and varied scientific
community as well to accomplish our
diversity goals we structured a rich and
multi-pronged engagement strategy
implemented by a network of healthcare
provider organizations direct volunteer
partners and community partners that
meets communities where they are is
sensitive to their needs and concerns
and also provides a strong foundation
for trust building that will hopefully
extend beyond the program itself so last
bit is particularly important because
developing the kind of data set for
which we're striving requires
consideration that often the groups were
trying the hardest to reach are
historically marginalized and oppressed
communities that may be wary of
scientific enterprise and government
involvement so in order to be successful
I mean we must earn these communities
trust in addition to the after mentioned
activities we're hoping to earn that
trust through conscientious robust
and respectful engagement and full
transparency and by empowering
participants as partners in this
endeavor our third and fourth core
values so when we say we regard our
participants as partners we mean it a
huge part of ensuring this program
serves diverse communities is listening
to those communities and incorporating
their views and feedback into the
structure of the program we're trying to
involve participants deeply in multiple
aspects of our program from deciding
what kind of data we collect and what
lab analyses we run on participant
samples to the kinds of research
conducted with the data resources and
the processes by which data gets
returned to participants so all of us as
we've mentioned is a longitudinal study
and we're hoping to capture data across
people's lifetimes it's hard to keep
people interested in something for that
long without especially without giving
them something in return which leads us
to our fifth core value that
participants will have access to
information and data about themselves so
as part of our covenant with
participants it revolves around ensuring
that participation is a valuable
endeavor and that value can be seen as
both public and personal all of us
offers
a way of giving back by contributing
data that will help create new cures for
disease helping to ensure that the data
reflects diverse communities and also by
being part of a movement a revolution if
you will that makes our healthcare more
precise more personal and more effective
but it also offers participants the
opportunity to learn about themselves
through their data so studies have shown
participants overwhelming they want
their information back it's a major
impetus for participation and research
in the first place and that information
is something that all of us can provide
as participants in all of us people will
have the opportunity to receive
information about everything from their
individual genomic results to
invitations to participate in other
research opportunities at the heart of
our stands and the return of information
is the concept of autonomy we believe
that the participant has the right to
know as much or as little about
themselves as they want as well as to
engage with the program at their chosen
level so this may fly in the face of a
perceived duty to inform but we believe
that there are legitimate interests and
not knowing one's status particularly
when it comes to genomic results that
the right not to know requires an
explicit choice on the part of the
participant that providing that choice
is appropriate in the context of this
program and that this stance enhances
individuals autonomy so while far come
from complete a serious discussions
around the return of results and
specifically the return of genetic
results started within this program over
a year ago in March of 2017 we held a
workshop where we hope to assess the
state of the field for return of genomic
information and to establish basic
guidelines for the return of genetic
results within the particular context of
all of us key insights from that meeting
about how to ensure that results are
communicated to participants with
different needs capabilities and
interests included first and foremost
that we need to ask participants if they
want data about themselves and how they
want that data this gets back to that
concept of autonomy we also need to
develop multiple modes with which to
communicate and for that we have to get
out and get visible with the communities
there are also challenges of the digital
divide and low literacy and health
literacy if we're to reach our goals we
need to be cognizant and sensitive to
those limitations
and bill means to overcome them success
is more likely also if we start small
with pilot studies on participant access
to information or ensure no results and
build up based on our findings rather
than trying to institute a mechanism or
mechanisms at scale in addition we
should sort of take a no surprises
policy we need to be realistic and
clearly communicate with participants
throughout their participation in the
program and lastly we don't need to go
this alone we should build upon best
practices and learn from others that
have gone before us to bolster the work
that's being done within the program NIH
has also partnered with FDA and CMS to
commissioned a study by the National
Academies of science on the return of
the results more generally the study
will bring together a range of diverse
perspectives to perform a review of the
current regulatory landscape and best
practices conduct an evaluation of harms
and benefits inherent in the present
system as well as consider additional
resources or alternative approaches that
may improve the process for returning
individual level results consensus
recommendations from that study are
expected this July so not so far away so
in addition to making this data
accessible to the participants we're
endeavoring to make a resource that is
available to a wide range of researchers
from different locations disciplines and
even levels of expertise as noted in our
sixth core value that goal of broad
accessibility forced us to become
creative with exactly how we can make
this work while still protecting the
privacy and security of our participants
so initially we plan to collect six
basic data modalities that are depicted
here but the data types that we collect
will adapt to the scientific and
technological climate as well as to the
level of trust built between the program
and our participants in terms of how
that wealth of data is made available
we're committed to creating a resource
that's accessible to the broadest range
of users possible our access and use
framework consists of a central curated
data Enclave that exists in the cloud
users access the data through an
analytical portal so unlike traditional
cohorts there's no data removal from the
centralized resource with the exception
of aggregate
analytical results all of the substitute
work with the data including with the
individual records and aggregate data
happens in that cloud so however not all
user access is created equal the data we
collect is separated by sensitivity into
public registered and controlled access
tiers users will be granted access to
one or more tiers and the level of
scrutiny
an applicant receives depends on the
level of access for which they're
applying the three primary tiers again
are the public tier and this is data
that poses minimal risk to the privacy
of research participants data in this
tier is presented only an aggregate and
has been to help prevent the possibility
of re-identification of participants
then there's the registered tier and the
register tier data has some risk of
identifying research participant and
therefore poses some risk to privacy it
can only be accessed after logging into
the research platform and this is the
tier where you start getting into
individual level data though more
sensitive individual level data is
restricted to the control tier control
tier data poses the most significant
risk to privacy of participants so
things like individual level sequence
data live here as well as clinical notes
and narrative data then there's sort of
a fourth tier of readily identifiable
data and this type of data will require
IRB review to access we've also adopted
a data passport model instead of project
proposals the approval board approves
researchers themselves after approval
users can then create multiple project
workspaces that live in the cloud and
these workspaces can be collaborative
bringing multiple users together on one
project provided that all of the users
have the requisite level of access for
each workspace the user then must
provide a description of the project the
contributors to that workspace including
information about those contributors
like when those contributors last
completed their ethics training for
example and then also the type of data
that's being used these project records
are then subjected to the panopticon so
anyone can essentially audit the
research that's being done in the
workspace particularly for research that
could be stigmatizing if someone comes
across such a project they can flag it
and that flag triggers a review by the
program's resource access board
so as part of all of us we ask
participants to give us very sensitive
data all of us takes the privacy and
security of this information extremely
seriously and in our seven core value
that we promise to abide by the PMI
privacy and Trust principles and the PMI
data security policy principles and
framework those documents drafted by the
White House Task Force in addition the
program is engaging teams of experts to
conduct rigorous security testing
establish safeguards against unintended
release of data and set penalties for
the unauthorized the identification of
participants we're also leveraging the
full extent of legal and regulatory
tools at our disposal to help ensure our
participants privacy including laws like
HIPAA the common rule Gina and the newly
strengthened certificates of
confidentiality
the latter is possibly one of our
greatest tools to ensure privacy and
actually comes from the same 21st
century cares act as the codification of
PMI so whereas in the past the issuance
of certificates was essentially optional
and the onus for the application for a
certificate rested with the researcher
issuance of certificates is now
mandatory and automatic for all
federally or partially federally funded
research collecting identifiable
sensitive information previously
certificates covered only identifiable
information certificates under the new
statute have recovered both identifiable
information and identifiable an
information that could be rendered
identifiable either by certain
technological procedures or in
conjunction with other available
information new certificates also cover
all copies of such information as well
as associated biospecimens and moreover
certificates now cover such data and
copies of data in perpetuity finally
before the Cure's act withholding was at
the discretion of the researcher or
research institution holding the
certificate now certificates mandate
withholding of data covered by the
certificate with several exceptions from
all non research personnel this includes
withholding from law enforcement
certificate holders are expected to use
all means at their disposal to uphold
participant privacy in response to legal
demands but even if data is disclosed
it's immune from the legal process and
inadmissible as evidence in legal and
other proceedings this
detection is completely new in the
statute as amended is by the Cure's Act
furthermore all certificates issued
prior to the effective date of the
statute are now imbued with the powers
and protections of the new law I feel
it's particularly important to clarify
these protections in light of the recent
news regarding the use of genetic
databases to determine the identity of
the Golden State Killer certificates of
confidentiality create robust privacy
protections not offered by commercial
genetic testing services in other words
the all of us data resources will not
may be wholly impervious to misuse are
not subject to the types of usage
they're stimulating the entire to
inquietude
that are expressed in articles like the
ones cited above so finally the all of
us research program efforts are meant to
enhance scientific discovery we're
aiming to create a resource that
catalyzes innovative inquiry broadly
across biomedical disciplines by having
rich diverse and comprehensive data we
hope to spur research that addresses an
array of biomedical objectives including
developing more accurate estimates of
disease risks that integrate
environmental and biological factors
adding to our knowledge of
pharmacogenomics refining and enhancing
our compendium of biomarkers using
mobile health technologies to inform
links between activity physiology
environment and health contributing to
the eradication of health disparities
and enabling trials of targeted
therapies in addition we hope that the
data we collect to empower our
participants with information that
facilitates the improvement of their own
health so where does the program to go
from here I think in addition to
building a resource that we have this
significant opportunity here as part of
all of us to stimulate research that
fuels evidence-based policy development
both from big P and little p policy and
it would be a shame to waste that
opportunity I would go even so far as to
say that we have a responsibility to the
rate of greater research community to
take advantage of it and we've accepted
this undertaking we envision that there
are four basic buckets of support that
all of us is poised to provide so there
is support for projects that address
policy implications of all of us or
research more broadly that evaluate
implementation and use of various laws
regulations or policies in the research
setting also support for projects that
assess the value of research to
stakeholders which gauge attitudes of
and impacts on stakeholder groups
towards or on research related topics
support for projects that directly
appraise aspects of research including
the effects of decision or policies on
the conduct of research itself and
finally support for convenings of the
ethical legal and social implications
research community and bioethics
communities so either current conveniens
or to form new ones so by the time you
will be hearing this talk all of us will
have just launched nationally we've been
doing a beta testing phase and we're
working like a technology platform
company centered on the user experience
so that means we have phased
implementation of program facets that
are first piloted iterated and scaled
over time we anticipate new technologies
protocols and assays that may be
integrated into the program and
throughout we will promise to provide
transparency and open access to our
protocols to enhance interoperability
with other cohorts as of today we have
nearly 30,000 people currently enrolled
in the program just well on our way to
our goal of 1 million participants and
with that thank you very much and I will
open it up to questions
thank you dr. Blizzard ski for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button once there as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is why is this program needed
so currently and despite the best
intentions of providers and researchers
health care is often a sort of one size
fits all and all of us is seeking to
advance precision medicine that
healthcare that's based on you as an
individual so our current way of doing
this can be costly for patients
providers and researchers patients may
not be served well by treatments
designed for the average patient
providers don't have enough
information available to provide
precision care for many conditions and
research has spent a lot of time and
resources building separate cohorts and
creating new IT systems databases and
analytical tools for each study that
they undertake assume well a single labs
resources may not be sufficient to
answer the research questions at hand so
all of us is about discovering new
precision medicine options for providers
and patients in the future by providing
a public resource that already has
volunteers infrastructure and data so
that researchers can get to the science
and the medical breakthrough is based on
their discoveries much faster and much
easier our next question is what makes
this program different from other
research programs cohorts or bio banks
so don't get me wrong but there are many
research programs that offer valuable
insights on health and disease all of us
has benefited from learning from cohort
programs that started before ours and
scientifically the cohorts more cohorts
that we have the better off we're going
to be several factors combined to make
all of us a unique research cohort
however there's diversity at scale so
our 1 million or more participants will
reflect rich diversity of the United
States including volunteers of many
races and ethnicities age groups
geographic regions gender identities
sexual orientations and health statuses
so it's a very very diverse cohort in a
very large one there's also many data
types so other large research programs
collect limited data types of samples or
data often focus on a specific disease
all of us will combine surveys data from
electronic health records blood and
urine samples physical measurements and
eventually wearable data to get a more
complete picture of human health across
many conditions also we view our
participants as partners so with all of
us participants are involved in multiple
aspects of our programs with ongoing
opportunities to help shape the program
with their input further data will be
shared with both researchers and
participants participants will have
access to their study information and
data about themselves with choices about
how much or how little that they want to
receive and finally broad access as a
government-funded program committed to
open data and science all of us will
make data broadly accessible to
researchers all kinds including citizen
scientists and support thousands of
studies across a wide range of different
health topics
and dr. bulczynski it looks like we have
time for one more question how is this
program funded so the Elvis research
program is publicly funded with
resources that are appropriated each
year by Congress the 21st century cures
Act passed in December of 2016
authorized a total of about 1.5 billion
dollars over ten years for the program
and those funds are subject to the
annual approach the appropriations
process so in fiscal year 2016 we
received one hundred and thirty million
dollars in five fiscal year 2017 that
was two hundred thirty million including
forty million from the 21st century's
cures act and in fiscal year 2018 we got
two hundred and ninety million including
a hundred million from the 21st century
care status and so that is an ongoing
process it will change every year I'd
like to once again thank dr. O Blizzard
ski for her presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I would like to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing your
August of 2018 you will receive an email
from laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
leg event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye